[Music]
an inmate at the grady county jail
this call is also subject to being
recorded or monitored
hello hi how are you doing mariana here
hi thank you so much for calling me it
all started
with an online reality show
the gay gun came redneck with a mullet
before netflix's hit
series tiger king made joe exotic famous
worldwide he was like a mythical
character living out in the middle of
oklahoma but lost in the hype
surrounding the ceilings
so joe says will you go to florida
[Music]
was a serious discussion about private
tiger ownership
in america i've been in the tiger
industry for a little over 20 years now
probably the largest breeder and handler
of tigers in the united states
so give me just a sense of the tiger
sort of
community cup petting zoos and all that
well to get in the world to pay for your
your hobbies
at least i was man enough to say look i
own a roadside zoo
and i break tigers you know i i'm stuck
i'm trying to figure out why the hell
i'm in jail first of all
to be clear joe exotic is behind bars
because he was convicted of the
attempted
murder for hire of carol baskin
as well as 17 wildlife crimes
in the words of the judge at joe exotic
sentencing
joe is a master manipulator who is
engaged in quote
systematic trafficking of tigers and
other big cats
yet critics of tiger king say the series
celebrated joe
while largely overlooking his treatment
of animals
joe is not a folk hero
he is somebody who for decades profited
off of the exploitation
and abuse of animals and joe is finally
where he belongs
so why would you want to breed a tiger
well
in the u.s roadside zoos can bring in
big money
by offering cup-heading experiences to
tourists
you know they raise tiger cubs so that
people can pay money and take selfies so
they have to have this constant supply
of these little tiny tiger cubs
between one and four months
so there's just this huge breeding
operation but the key thing here is that
after the cubs are about four months old
they're too dangerous to
for the public to handle they need to be
handed off somewhere
and often i don't think we really know
what happens to them to understand the
scope of the issue
national geographic magazine reviewed
joe exotic's records
from 2010 to 2018 and learned that the
zoo traded nearly
200 tigers with dozens of other private
owners
across america breeders like joe are one
of the reasons that there are now
an estimated five to ten thousand tigers
in the united states
with less than four thousand tigers left
in the wild
there are now more tigers living in
captivity in the u.s
than there are wild tigers living in the
rest of the world
if something's endangered hell we need
to start breeding it do we not
is that not what the purpose of being
endangered is
we need more of
[Music]
you